finish the ball Dellavedova on him again
kidding me did he seriously do that
Bayless gets in there LeBron right there
with the block Wow I mean he just takes
your breath away
and the brown want to keep going with
the ball
yeah he did bilis thinks he hasn't
stopped oh every leave star warner you
must get to him before he gets the ball
Mira great timing but the quickness you
don't talk about it be about it dear
James chases heads-down protects the rim
and prevents a San Antonio score curving
drives well defend his ball knocked away
by Barnes Vega dalla ahead to curry
Shumpert in pursuit blocked by James
rejects it out of bounds
good hustle defensively he's down
blocked by LeBron good job not giving up
on the foot
Irving drives hop step inside close up
misses rebound taken by Iguodala
they go down with a curry back there get
down up for the lamp Oh blocked by James
LeBron James with the rejection great
pass by curry
running hard by Iguodala and superhuman
defensive recovery by LeBron James
once this season hit the preseason
here's Lee this is not fair you missed
it in the first half Marv that he wanted
to let somebody go by him so he could
block it I think he did the same thing
on this play almost even sported from
black
my fragment change back
look at this block he's challenging brat
first of all James Jones cut off by
Chris Cody and it's stolen by bloodstone
chased by Irving tackler play by LeBron
James
Courtney Lee don't feel bad I've been
there brother
well I thought Millsap got away with a
push on Tristan Thompson and James with
an emphatic block on Sefolosha time MVP
the mistakes twice
on the pipes comes out of nowhere great
timing from abroad on the backside is
Turner didn't fail him back there and no
no they want that switch you want to
switch of teague on LeBron you gotta get
this they turn over James and a
chase-down block he erased it can I on
him I watch it sagal turn he's gonna
dump it off in that game once you did
that slow down gave LeBron not NOLA
extra half a step
what of defensive effort here by LeBron
James
and Avery Bradley welcome to the club he
goes right at James steps by James since
a slow recovery headed to seven all of a
sudden stop the ball here come inside
what does the chemo he's due to a prince
that he puts in his place big time
quarter but LeBron James that is called
two tickets that reduce tonight in the
championship game get that weak stuff
out of here oh yeah he caught it before
I got to the ball but before the board
and put it on the board
yep fourth overall traded jetty Iseman a
part of that deal became a steal by
Jones that's what he can really do gets
all the way
a free lane in the bucket in LeBron
James chased him down and he couldn't
fight at the apex to ready to top
good timing everything there King and
the chase death comes down looking for
the switch oh there's one second
remaining could add maybe a few tenths
of a second as you see the incredible
rejection from LeBron James